de ces consultations s'il de vraiment
comprendre comment notre cadre de
politique monétaire pour effecter des
gens de façon différente et savoir à
quel prix on pourrait tenir sa en compte
la première sous-gouverneur de la banque
du canada car les nouveaux kenzy qui
explique pourquoi la banque 102 les
canadiens en vue du renouvellement de
l'entente sur le cadre de la politique
monétaire
le sondage s'appelle parlons inflation
et le questionne donc la population sur
une série de façon de faire que pourrait
adopter la banque du canada depuis 1993
de la banque à une cible d'inflation
annuel de 2% ce qui veut dire que le
prix de votre panier d'épicerie doblo au
bout de 35 ans dans les années 70 avec
une inflation plus élevée le prix de
l'épicerie doublé après seulement dix
ans alors je parle de cette façon de
faire avec mon invité stéphane marion il
est économiste et stratège en chef à la
banque nationale bonjour monsieur mario
joue alors le mandat de la banque du
canada c'est renouvelable aux cinq ans
chaque fois la banque consultent des
experts des groupes d'intérêts mais
cette fois on ajoute la population
canadienne inscrite une bonne idée
d'après vous bah moi je pense qu'on a la
technologie pour être plus transparent
donc je pense que c'est une opération
louable mais entendons-nous là quand
même
ce sera peut-être pas un sondage
représentatif
parce qu'en général pour naviguer sur le
site de la banque du canada est un
public averti et questions que l'on pose
peuvent être ainsi techniques dont on
regarde ce sondage là donc oui une
consultation oui ou non de la
transparence faut le faire mais
représentatif de l'ensemble de la
population bien sûr j'en doute parce que
le sondage prend une dizaine de minutes
à remplir certaines questions comme vous
l'évoquez sont faciles à comprendre
d'autres concernent des concepts qui
sont un peu plus pointus comme
encourager les canadiens justement y
répondre la banque du canada a facilité
tout ça mais encore une fois en bout de
ligne je pense que la décision ultime à
savoir s'ils ont reconduit ou non la
cible et dans quelle mesure on mettre
d'autres bas rhin
pourrait influencer la politique
monétaire ce sont essentiellement des
consultations qui auront lieu entre la
banque du canada et les autorités
publiques donc à savoir le ministère des
finances donc je pense que si on
politiciens la banque du canada de
décider en de consulter la population
d'accord mais encore une fois je doute
que le sondage - représentent qu'un
tiers par ces questions sont quand même
a cité le canadien moyen plus décidé
justement des choses aussi complexe
l'approchent actuel monsieur mario c'est
d'ajuster les taux d'intérêt pour
maintenir l'inflation à 2 %
est ce que la banque pourrait changer
cette approche en 2021
mais quand même une chose à dire en faut
admettre que le 2% soit c'est facile à
comprendre pour tout le monde on est une
cible de choix
la pensionnaire quand même bien réussi
depuis le début on navigue autour de la
c'est donc une visibilité que les
canadiens ont qui n'est pas une semaine
visibilité qui partager dans par rapport
à tous les autres pays du monde donc ça
c'est très bien
par contre je vous dirais que dans un
conteste un contexte post endémique
peut-être le 2% devient peu simpliste et
qu'on devrait peut-être ajouter un cadre
où on parle de peut-être minimiser le
taux de chômage passe qu'entendons-nous
bien elle dans un environnement post
pandémique
il est possible que tout chômage se
retrouve un niveau plus élevé qu'avant
la récession
cavani me donc peut-être fort calibre il
message d'abandon
quel est donc le 2 % d'accord ça nous a
bien servi mais peut-être conditionnel
de façon à nous laisser une marge de
manoeuvre pour maximiser l'emploi puis
peut-être aussi pour faciliter la
stabilité financière donc des mandats
qui pourrait être rajouté en plus du
dieu pour cela parce que l'espèce
actuelle vous le dit elle est fragile ce
serait donc un bon moment pour peut-être
changer de cadre à la banque du canada
s'est aussitôt nadhoim que que le
changement de cible s'opère dans les
cinq ans et ça jacques demain donc que
ça donne dans un contexte post
pandémique donc une récession qui a été
causé par une pandémie et quelles sont
les ramifications les changements
structurels qui viendront après la
pandémie
je pense que l'occasion est bonne pour
peut-être recadrer un peu le message
la banque du canada se donner peut-être
une cible de 2% mais avec conditionnelle
à certaines autres indicateurs donc je
pense que c'est le temps le moment evian
tout est bien choisi pour repenser à
tout ça
peut-on s'inspirer monsieur marion de ce
qui se passe ailleurs dans le monde par
exemple des modèles qui fonctionnent
différemment et qui pourrait justement
être peut-être mieux dans la situation
actuelle au canada ainsi qu'aux états
unis j'ai un mandat double une inflation
relativement stable eux ils ont adopté
un tout de mesures canadiens en mettant
un chiffre donc une bonne nouvelle par
exemple fédéral c'est relativement
récent par contre c'est clair la réserve
fédérale au ici un bandeau de minimiser
le taux de chômage mandat qui n'existe
pas au canada donc encore une fois dans
un contexte post pandémique avec un taux
de chômage qui pourrait t'appeler 2 me
je vis pour un bon moment que de
recadrer la politique monétaire
canadienne en ajoutant le bémol du taux
de chômage à rajouter de la transparence
par rapport à la politique monétaire qui
est mise en place
alors c'est une première ce sondage
auprès des canadiens ça se passe
jusqu'au 1er octobre en ligne il faudra
voir combien de canadiens justement vont
s'intéresser et puis jusque dans quelle
mesure ils seront écoutés pour ce
prochain cadres comme vous le disiez il
y aura des experts qui vont aussi être
consultées bien sûr merci beaucoup
stéfane marion
le giron voix au revoir
[Musique]